hey everyone and welcome to Westeros
weekly your ultimate game of Thrones
after-show I'm Liana Galera I'm a
skeleton and we're breaking down
everything that happened in last night's
episode plus each week we're going to
giving you exclusive interviews from
Game of Thrones stars and your favorite
Game of Thrones
superfan today we have Edie Sheeran and
Kit Harington who's that never heard of
them no not at all oh let's kick things
off with the Nights Watch
tonight's watch everything that happened
last night I think everybody is talking
about what the name Arya Stark are in
sorry oh my gosh that moment that
cold-open was the coldest open we've
ever had thank you in Game of Thrones
history let's take a quick look at what
happened the one wolf alive and the
Sheik I never saved no that is not
Walder Frey it's Arya Stark in that line
Jaime
whoa we'll get well move on to that one
that's we're going to come back to that
and we're going to come back to that
we're going to dissect out a little bit
deeper what's the internet talking about
the Internet is talking all about the
fact that Ed Sheeran with in last
night's episode no he was not singing
shape of you he was singing something
else something a little prettier let's
let's take a look at that little woman -
pretty song I've never had it before
janila of course he was singing cheeky
cheesy response there ed Sheeran
Ashleigh controversial opinion I don't
know if I would necessarily need it that
in last night's episode okay it's like
I'm escaping into this fantasy world and
then I see Ed Sheeran essentially
playing ed Sheeran he might as well
descend like hi I'm sir ed it took me
out of it oh I really hear it yeah I
also felt like that scene could have
been in any episode well 100% boobs like
every line and scene in that show serves
a purpose except for though and I almost
would have loved it if Arya's big moment
of the night had just been that cold
open absolutely and we actually caught
up with Ed Sheeran last month and here
what he actually had to say about his
cameo I feel like my cameo has been
throw up too much some people will just
be like oh alright like it's not an
integral part of it at all I'm just like
in it thank you and you
we also got the grossest scene I've ever
seen on Game of Thrones that montage
with Sam and in the Citadel and the bed
pans and though yeah I was trying to
drink wine and then I got a little
nauseous I'm not even kidding but it was
kind of the funniest scene that we've
ever had in Game of Thrones totally what
ghosts is like oh I'm not having this
having it at all but we also got a bear
look at a crime in a turn yes Jorah
hello alright you're looking great man
not quite
I saw that hand reaching out it looks
like the grayscale is in full effect
right now mm-hmm what do you think he's
there for that's what I called you right
after because I was like is he captured
or is he there on his own will or he I
think I think he's being studying
because remember Danny had said you need
to find a cure that's the only way that
you can come back and be at my side you
need to save your own life and I feel
like going to the Citadel and being
amongst the most the smartest men in
Westeros is the only way to do it right
yeah and then we also have Sam doing his
little Harry Potter thing going into the
restrictions restricted section I felt
like I was watching Harry Potter so many
people were just like oh my gosh this is
straight out of Harry Potter first he
was Bell now he's Harry Potter oh um any
fines that Dragonstone had a mountain of
dragonglass which is the way to kill the
white Walker exactly so of course he
sends a raven to Jon Snow so hopefully
that means that we will be getting a Jon
Snow engine area scene pretty soon are
they going to get along time will tell
I don't know so they are related going
and of course we gotta talk about Cersei
ah not wanting at all to talk about the
fact that all of her children are dead
doesn't even really seem to care them
not not really she is hell-bent on
keeping control of the Seven Kingdoms I
loved when Jamie came in with that cool
line your rulings three kingdoms at best
sweetheart this holds our whole
everything with Cersei which is like a
ton of shade because then of course
you're on comes in yes which is proposal
to marry her which is a could be a good
alliance
but right now he's kind of b-team like
there's no reason it doesn't really
benefit her to be with him can we talk
about his wonderful makeover I'm not
sure how I feel about it right now last
year he's very serious and this year he
comes in he's cheeky kind of is giving
me like Jeff over like what's a hot
topic a little gossiping going on
guyliner on point yeah so he does say
that he you know she rejects his
proposal and he says I'm going to go get
you a gift yes the ultimate gift to will
accrue a queen which maturity you're not
going to vales like what do you think
he's getting her I think he's going to
get her a head whose head Sansa and I
don't that pains understand all rude I
know how rude but like think about it
like oh she hates so many people it
could be anyone I think she probably
wants Tyrion the most you say yes
because he did betray her in because
he's the kind of Queen Danny but I don't
know if he's going to get him I don't
know you got to go three dragons and I'm
going to get him I think it's going to
be somebody else but sounds of a good
guess I really don't want her to be hurt
anymore than sheriffy she's been hurt
enough guys enough Lin says alone ah
let's move over to the iciest moment of
the night oh my gosh well that's
circling back to what we were talking
about at the beginning hands down it
belongs to all right sorry Sark alright
how dark as Walder Frey yeah I'm
lighting it's Walder Frey yeah the whole
the whole unmasking and just the line
she says I mean let's take a look at it
I know myself
when people ask you what happened here
tell you enough for members tell them
winter came for House Frey I just got to
I was the only time well I screamed
twice during the episode of that and
then when we felt hormone of course yeah
definitely first um so you guys are
going to learn this very soon on
actually it's got a raging crush on
dormant love tour mom I love him so much
but I love how incredibly badass Arya
was in this episode not only did she
cross off so many names from her list
that she did it in such a wonderful
fashion I hope she keeps doing this
every episodes of cold-open sorry I
didn't kill doing somebody okay here's
my question
is she allowed to keep using the skills
that she learned from the faceless men
even though she's no longer an assassin
yeah seems like a seems like it stuff
shouldn't be allowed but alright but all
out will allow it this time Ashley take
us into our next thing should we do a
segment we're calling Keeping Up with
Khaleesi honestly she gets our first
line of the season the only line that
Danny said but it was worth the wait
worth the way it was take a look
shall we begin ah she's home she's home
she's home I just love that she okay we
just got a silent montage of her
exploring Dragonstone her family home
this is the first time that she's been
back there since she was an itty bitty
baby because they were exiled from it
and just watching her just see
everything for the first time and walk
up those steps and I just loved it yeah
I absolutely love us and by the way the
whole reason that was unoccupied and
here like why is there's just an empty
castle Miska Stannis was their Santa and
why are we not around anymore but that's
why that that throne room and then that
war room looks so familiar for those
fans who might have forgot that oh yeah
Stan is just kind of like like well dibs
dibs okay and if there was another thing
that you might have been a little bit
fuzzy on in last night's episode we're
here to catch you up with a segment we
like to call the North remember take it
away Ashley well there was this whole
situation with the Hound that you
definitely got the you got the feeling
you were like this was some time suppose
remember from previous seasons and I did
not at all he gets to the cabin you know
he finds this this farmer in the
foothill girl and they're dead and you
can he there gets to a point where he
buries them and he clearly knew them
knew them so back in season four when
he's on his adventure with Aria they
actually take them in they feed them all
the stuff and then he beats them up and
robs them and doesn't feel bad about it
and says well they're gonna be dead by
winter this guy's weak he can't defend
themselves so I don't even feel bad sick
move the hound because that we get you
know we get back here and they're
calling him Sandor Clegane by the way
they're certain to call him by his name
which is like a pretty clever I think
writing thing to kind of fish his moral
ground but he he feels guilty and he
buries them and he clearly is kind of
thought about it I know but like it was
something that I totally forgot about
the fact that this happened three
seasons ago yeah and it's just crazy to
see how much Aria has changed just from
what we were just seeing of her right oh
my gosh but no so I definitely thought
that it was something that we needed to
revisit and but we're getting a call
from this we have a stark sister update
wonderful
[Music]
did salsa start in Arya Stark reunite in
tonight's episode nope
this has been your Stark's sister update
[Music]
moving on restricting on each week we
are going to be catching up with your
favorite game of Thrones stars or Game
of Thrones superfans
and we are going to be asking them our
wildfire Fast Five round of questions
it's going to be the same for every
person and so we're going to see how
their answers stack up this week we
caught up with the one the only Kit
Harington who plays Jon Snow look at
that we've got our little baby ghost
here to represent him so let's take a
look at all kids answers and see what he
had to say
from Michelle Fairley Irv Katherine stop
like a bit of a smile a big smile grey
worm and bread I guess the problem with
the answer no one knows she deserves it
when you had peg true
Karen it's that's interesting I also
just think he's like a great adviser
handed the King I don't know if he could
actually rule I think that he's very
wise and I think that he's very
intelligent but I don't know if he's
quite up for the task and that was not
exactly a height puns and I just
realized that it kind of was really
sorry
speaking of the Iron Throne we are going
to move on to a segment we're calling
race to the iron throne who is the top
contenders right now right now we've got
the Lannisters way in the lead and
that's going to be because they're
actually on the iron throne physically
that's right they're in King's Landing
this is the percent of Circe herself is
actually sitting on the throne and not
just using her children as puppets and
she doesn't even seem to care I think
like one thing that's an advantage for
her is that she just has no moral
compass she does not care at all yeah
she has no heart so I really feel like
it's not to be difficult for her to just
kill everyone that she needs to Pinet or
in order to keep the throne a second
place who's really heating up right now
Miss Daenerys Targaryen he does have a
moral compass yes and shut a castle
she's got three dragon he's got
thousands and ships she really has what
it takes to really overtake it right now
I feel like she is Cersei's biggest
opponent absolutely and then in third
place I think no one we like probably
one it was John yeah
he's obviously butting heads with Sansa
like a lot but a lot like sister brother
squabbles but in front of everyone like
that was like a really awkward
Thanksgiving moment with them I think if
she wasn't his sister he'd probably have
to discard her she does make a fair
point she did say in last night's
episode you need
smarter than Ned you need to be smarter
than Rob I think she's great for him I
think she's great she's a good hand of
the King but I do think that with
Littlefinger like whispering her in her
ear okay wife you realm like he's all
like he's always gonna be around I know
he doesn't benefit like I thought he's
always but he's always there and he's
just like ready and willing I wouldn't
be surprised if by the end of the series
it's like everyone's Jen he just kind of
sled oh I'd be furious it's on that
throws I need piss too but like at the
same time he's like a cockroach yeah he
is like a cockroach you know just can't
kill him but oh right now Lannister's in
the lead I'm really hoping that they get
dethroned soon me too yeah we do get our
teaser for next week's episode episode
which is jam-packed well I'll take a
look at that look how Darren cannot be
trusted the mad Kings daughters will
destroy the realm we have an army a
fleet and three dragons we should hit
king landing now
ah Bakshi Zack time area and Aria seem
like they're going to reunite it does
not seem like it's going to go well did
it look like they were having a great
connection there but many of the North
remembers member a long time ago Aria
had to banish the Miriah because clearly
Cersei and Joffrey was going to have her
killed because she bit Joffrey which is
another reason to be in love with this
dire wolf but so I can't imagine that
she would be too pleased we are you
again because she managed her and we
also saw that Targaryen can't be trusted
yeah well weaving John got the letter
from Sam so alright we're getting closer
to them being in the same vicinity of
each other I'm so excited for that to
happen I I don't even know what their
first exchange would be disick hey
auntie do you think yeah being related
to somebody doesn't really matter in
Westeros so do you think they're gonna
you think they're do you think they're
going to get together I don't know if a
brother and sister can hook up why not
an antenna and an SEO oh that just
doesn't cut that out of contact I just
uh and of course speaking of hookups
ah get it girl Yaron ilaria uh hi make
it out I had it though you really
attractive females hooking up like
that's great yeah yeah I'm all about it
I also really enjoyed the fact that
Cersei throw-in shade at Danny Singh the
mad Kings daughter can't be trusted to
rule the kingdom you know her she's way
sir she's way matters when I blew up
half your kingdom girl don't be throwing
stone just ragged and queen blue but
there is so much goodness ahead for us
six more episodes that was a personal
one Ashley on the spot right now we did
not practice this what do you think is
going to happen and who do you think is
gonna die this season or next episode
this season um who I think I think John
and Danny are gonna meet yes I think
gosh I don't want Spencer to die oh wow
you're gone real dark I'm making like a
bold prediction okay well if I do get it
I feel like I was going to do an
underhand and be like I think Podrick is
going to die but you just really
disprove right down oh man oh I can't
watch
haha I definitely think we're going to
get more unlikely team ups I would like
to see Arya and criterion has it seems
other a while you know when you said to
me earlier Breanna and grey worm oh
because John gave me that idea or a kid
gave me that idea I could John John's
now sorry ah I know so many good things
coming ahead I'm still shipping torment
Umbreon they need to get together I mean
if they don't get together then there's
no justice in the world but all that
next week house all of that next week
we've got so much more of you guys thank
you so much for tuning into our first
episode of Westeros weekly be sure to
keep checking back cuz we're going to be
having exclusive interviews from all
your favorite game of Thrones stars and
welcoming in some Game of Thrones
superfans into the mix absolutely like
comment subscribe and you can always
tweet us about Game of Thrones or
whatever else you want talk about yeah
anything subtle game we're game room
thanks so much for taking my bye guys